construir modelos
que pueden predecir todo tipo de atributos ocultos
de Uds. que ni siquiera Uds. conocen,
de los que comparten información.
Como científicos, usamos eso para ayudar
a interactuar en línea,
pero hay aplicaciones menos altruístas,
y existe un problema en el desconocimiento del usuario
de estas técnicas y de su funcionamiento,
y aún de conocerlas, no tenemos demasiado control sobre ellas.
Por eso hoy quiero hablarles
de algunas cosas que podemos hacer,
y luego brindar ideas para avanzar,
para devolverle un poco de control a los usuarios.
Esta es Target, la empresa.
No solo puse ese logo
en el vientre a esa pobre mujer embarazada.
Es posible que hayan visto la anécdota que salió
en Forbes, en la que Target
le envió un volante a esta chica de 15 años
con anuncios y cupones
para biberones, pañales y cunas
2 semanas antes de que le dijera a sus padres
que estaba embarazada.
Sí, el padre estaba muy molesto.
Dijo: "¿Cómo adivinó Target
que esta chica de secundaria estaba embarazada
antes de que se lo diga a sus padres?"
Resulta que ellos tienen el historial de compras
de cientos de miles de clientes
y calculan lo que llaman puntaje de embarazo,
que no se trata de si la mujer está o no embarazada,
sino para cuándo espera.
Y lo calculan
no mirando cosas obvias
como si compra una cuna o ropa de bebé,
sino cosas como si compró más vitaminas
de lo normal,
o si compró un bolso de mano
suficientemente grande como para contener pañales.
Y por sí solas, dichas compras no parecen
revelar mucho,
pero es un patrón de comportamiento que,
tomado en el contexto de miles de otras personas,
empieza a revelar algunas ideas.
Ese es el tipo de cosas que hacemos
al predecir en los medios sociales.
Buscamos pequeños patrones de comportamiento que,
al detectarlos entre millones de personas,
nos permiten encontrar todo tipo de cosas.
En mi laboratorio, junto a mis colegas,
hemos desarrollado mecanismos en los que podemos
predecir cosas con bastante exactitud
como sus preferencias políticas,
su puntaje de personalidad, género, orientación sexual,
religión, edad, inteligencia,
además de cosas como
cuánto confían en las personas que conocen
y cuán fuertes son esas relaciones.
Podemos hacer todo esto muy bien.
Y, de nuevo, no viene de lo que podría
pensarse como información obvia.
Mi ejemplo preferido es este estudio
publicado este año
en las Actas de la Academia Nacional.
Si lo buscan en Google, lo encontrarán.
Tiene 4 páginas, es fácil de leer.
Mirando los "me gusta" de Facebook,
o sea, las cosas que nos gustan en Facebook,
usaron eso para predecir todos estos atributos,
y algunos otros.
En su artículo listaron los 5 "me gusta"
más indicativos de una inteligencia alta.
Entre ellos figuraba el "me gusta"
de las papas rizadas. (Risas)
Las papas rizadas son deliciosas,
pero que les gusten no necesariamente significa
que sean más inteligentes que la media.
Entonces, ¿cómo es que uno de los indicadores más fuertes
de inteligencia
sea darle "me gusta" a esta página
si el contenido es totalmente irrelevante
para el atributo que se predice?
Resulta que tenemos que mirar
un montón de teorías subyacentes
para ver por qué podemos hacer esto.
Una de ellas es una teoría sociológica llamada homofilia,
que dice que básicamente las personas son amigas de personas como ellos.
Así, si uno es inteligente, tiende a ser amigo de personas inteligentes
y si es joven, tiende a ser amigo de jóvenes
y esto está bien establecido
desde hace cientos de años.
También sabemos mucho
sobre cómo se difunde la información por las redes.
Resulta ser que los videos virales,
los "me gusta" de Facebook, u otra información
se difunden exactamente de la misma manera
que las enfermedades por las redes sociales.
Por eso es algo que hemos estudiado durante mucho tiempo.
Tenemos buenos modelos de esto.
Juntando estas cosas
empezamos a ver por qué ocurren cosas como estas.
Si tuviera que hacer una hipótesis,
diría que un tipo inteligente lanzó esta página
o fue quizá uno de los primeros "me gusta"
que puntuó alto en esa prueba.
Les gustó, y sus amigos lo vieron,
y por homofilia, sabemos que probablemente tenía amigos inteligentes,
por eso se los propagó, y a alguno le gustó,
y ellos tenían amigos inteligentes,
y se lo propagaron a ellos,
y así se expandió por la red
a una serie de personas inteligentes,
y así, al final, la acción
de darle "me gusta" a las papas rizadas
es indicio de inteligencia superior,
no debido al contenido,
sino por la acción de darle "me gusta"
que refleja el atributo en común
con otras personas que hicieron lo mismo.
Es complicado, ¿no?
Es algo difícil de explicar
al usuario medio, y aún de hacerlo,
¿qué puede hacer al respecto el usuario medio?
¿Cómo saber que uno dio un "me gusta"
que indica un rasgo propio
totalmente irrelevante al contexto del "me gusta"?
Los usuarios no tienen demasiado poder
para controlar el uso de estos datos.
Y veo eso como un verdadero problema en el futuro.
Por eso creo que hay un par de caminos
a mirar
si queremos darle a los usuarios algo de control
sobre cómo se usan estos datos,
porque no siempre se van a usar
en su beneficio.
Un ejemplo que doy a menudo es que,
si alguna vez me aburro de ser profesora,
fundaré una empresa
que prediga todos estos atributos
y cosas como cuán bien uno trabaja en equipo,
o si uno es drogadicto, o alcohólico.
Sabemos cómo predecir eso.
Y le venderé informes
a empresas de RR.HH. y a grandes empresas
que quieran contratarlos.
Hoy, podemos hacerlo.
Podría lanzar esa empresa mañana,
y Uds. no tendrían ningún control
para que no use sus datos de esa forma.
Eso me parece que es un problema.
Por eso podemos transitar las vías
políticas y legales.
En algunos aspectos, creo que sería más eficaz
pero el problema es que deberíamos hacerlo.
Al observar nuestro proceso político en acción
pienso que es muy poco probable
conseguir que un grupo de representantes
se siente, se documenten al respecto,
y luego promulguen cambios radicales
a la ley de propiedad intelectual de EE.UU.
para que los usuarios controlen sus datos.
Podríamos ir por las políticas,
las empresas de medios sociales dicen
¿Sabes? Eres dueño de tus datos.
Tienes total control de cómo se usan.
El problema es que los modelos de ingresos
de la mayoría de las empresas de medios sociales
dependen de compartir o explotar los datos de usuario de alguna manera.
A veces se dice de Facebook que los usuarios
no son el cliente, sino el producto.
Entonces, ¿cómo hacer que una empresa
le ceda el control de su activo principal
nuevamente a los usuarios?
Es posible, pero no creo que sea algo
que veamos cambiar rápidamente.
Por eso creo que la otra vía
que podemos transitar es la de ser más eficaces,
la de aplicar más ciencia.
La de hacer más ciencia que nos permita desarrollar
todos estos mecanismos para calcular
estos datos personales en primer lugar.
Es una investigación muy similar
a la que deberíamos hacer
si quisiéramos desarrollar mecanismos
que le digan al usuario:
"Este es el riesgo de la acción que acabas de hacer".
Al darle "me gusta" a esa página en Facebook,
o al compartir esa información personal,
mejoraste mi capacidad
de predecir si usas drogas
o si te llevas bien en el trabajo.
Y eso, creo, puede afectar que
las personas quieran compartir algo,
mantenerlo privado, o desconectado por completo.
También podemos ver cosas como
permitirle a las personas cifrar los datos que suben,
para que sean invisibles o sin valor
para sitios como Facebook
o servicios de terceros que los acceden
pero que los usuarios que la persona seleccionó
puedan verlos.
Esta es una investigación súper interesante
desde el punto de vista intelectual,
de modo que los científicos estarán encantados de hacerla.
Eso nos da una ventaja sobre la vía legal.
Uno de los problemas que surgen
cuando hablo de esto
es que si las personas empiezan a mantener estos datos privados
todos esos métodos desarrollados
para predecir sus rasgos fallarán.
Y yo digo que para mí es un éxito total,
porque como científica,
mi objetivo no es inferir información de los usuarios,
sino mejorar la interacción de las personas en línea.
A veces, eso implica inferir cosas sobre ellos,
pero si los usuarios no quieren que use esos datos,
creo que deberían tener el derecho a pedirlo.
Quiero usuarios informados, que aprueben
las herramientas que desarrollamos.
Por eso creo que incentivar este tipo de ciencia
y apoyar a los investigadores
que quieran ceder algo del control nuevamente a los usuarios
y quitárselo a las empresas de medios sociales
implica avanzar, y que esas herramientas evolucionen
y avancen,
significa que tendremos una base de usuarios
educados y con poder.
Y creo que todos estamos de acuerdo
en que es una manera bastante ideal de avanzar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)